a cry for help as coastlines of
vulnerable island states vanish under
rising sea levels
a distress call as Suede's of the
ancient ice sheets of Greenland and the
Antarctic melt away and the Arctic sea
ice diminishes rapidly a white flag as
our most emblematic coral reefs Earth's
single biggest living structure succumb
to bleaching these are no longer warning
shots these are not signals but symptoms
our ocean is suffering some of the most
dramatic and damaging effects of climate
change
greenhouse gas emissions generated by
human activity are causing sea
temperatures to rise faster than ever
recorded destabilizing ecosystems and
reducing biodiversity these same
emissions are changing our oceans very
chemistry increased acidification and
caused by carbon dioxide jeopardizes
whole species of marine life including
plankton the very basis of it all
[Music]
absorbing up to 90% of excess greenhouse
heat our ocean is doing more than its
share to help regulate the Earth's
climate and diminish the effects of
climate change
now it is our turn to act if we denote
extreme weather conditions such as
cyclones and tropical storms were only
increase wreaking havoc in coastline
communities and threatening to sweep
away vulnerable traditional livelihoods
so how will we fight climate change
how will we mitigate its effects on us
our Islands our coasts and our ocean
[Music]